sion l'auteur du crime raciste de
dunkerque a été mise en examen pour
assassinat
au moment de son transfert vers le
palais justice des incidents éclatent et
des manifestants ont jeté des pierres
ignorant les appels au calme lancés par
la famille de la victime pierre nicolas
en milieu d'après midi le suspect sous
bonne escorte vient entendre sa mise en
examen pour tentative d'assassinât et
assassinat devant l'entrée du palais de
justice une partie de la foule
elle l'a déjà jugé quelques dizaines de
jeunes le visage à moitié masqué jettent
des pierres sur les forces de l'ordre
un homme blessé est à terre il est
déplacé sans ménagement alors que son
pantalon se consume plusieurs
adolescents sont arrêtés ils ne
protestent pas seulement contre la mort
d'un jeune homme de 17 ans mais contre
ces policiers qui protège un tireur aux
motivations racistes car le suspect a
semble-t-il avoué que son geste était
adressée aux seuls maghrébins il
explique temps-là phénomène l'énervement
lié sans doute qu'il n'était pas x ça
c'est certain mais un problème il avait
bu un peu d'alcool dans la journée il
s'est énervé il a décidé de partir en
expédition
maintenant il regrette son geste parce
qu'il se rend compte de
la bêtise in énorme qu'il a fait ce
qu'il dit il le regrette mais les partis
en expédition dans le quartier de grande
synthe beaucoup regrettent ces
débordements
la famille de mohamed magar avait
pourtant lancé un appel au calme et
plusieurs leaders associatifs avaient
tenté de canaliser la colère de certains
j'ai vue d'aider des jeunes révoltés
gelé soutenu j écoutais parlé avec
violence parler avec votre avec vos
tripes avec vous votre coeur parler mais
pas des haines
cilaïne trouve pas un appel qui n'a donc
pas été complètement entendu en fin
d'après-midi les abords du palais de
justice de dunkerque que ressemblait à
un champ de bataille ce soir l'assassin
présumé a été écroué et le calme semble
être revenu